but still you had a a video of you in a
bathing suit looking good walking out of
the water selling your sexuality for
attention right like that is one of the
ways that that women use their beauty to
get attention by showing off their body
and skin and being hey check me out look
at me I'm Latina AF guys can't do that
right AR SE the new Kim Kardashian
videos uh that she's selling her skims
line uh I don't know the athlete that's
in it but uh anybody's welcome to look
it up Kim kashan who's known for using
her body and her face is now using men
and their bodies and their faces she has
this video that I mean I was scrolling
Instagram I'm like wait he is you know
so I don't think we're the only ones we
just happen to be able to do
it you know maybe better isn't it isn't
it interesting though that like your
immediate reaction when I put that tweet
was you put a picture of yourself up
going hey I'm 40 whatever Mom of four
kids you know did I hit the wall do I
look good and it's like you know you got
some positive feedback you got some
negative feedback on it but you got the
feedback you know at the end of day but
you defaulted immediately immediately to
look at me with makeup and a a hot red
dress on and check me out for positive
reinforcement right Beauty right so like
like you're like you're legit confirming
what I talk about when I say women are
Beauty objects the only difference is
that what I'm saying is that is that
women seem to have some difficulty
understanding that there's an expiry
date on their beauty
right okay and that expiry date is 23
that's that's when they tend to go on
the on the decline that's what Society
culture cross continent cross cultures
all agree on I know that women don't
like to agree on that pardon I mean
that's fine what happens to a woman
after 23 according well her value slowly
diminishes because her beauty starts to
go downhill I mean it's why women get
what sense what is her value so her
value is subjective what is her value
her value is her beauty and that's
primarily in well you're you're 44 right
that is correct yeah so I'm assuming by
now you probably dye your hair to get
rid of the Grays you've done this is my
natural hair color I have not dyed you
can actually see a few Grays okay but I
mean like you do things to beautify your
appearance right like you put on makeup
eyelash extens do your nails I do not do
eyelash extensions I do my nails these
are my nails yeah like the standard
stuff that women typically do to amplify
Beauty like the Optics of beauty sure so
why even bother doing that if you're not
a beauty
object I never said that I wasn't either
I mean I like looking good why do you
shave because you're you're not a beauty
object why do you bother you know taking
care of yourself do you iron your
clothes I mean it it's kind of like
where are we today in in society we can
go down this path there's things that
you do too do you go to the gym why do
you go to the gym I mean certainly
you've passed your your expiry
date
yeah I mean question why do I go to the
gym yeah why do why do you well maybe
not the gym the gym could be for your
health why do you take care of
yourself well it's it's incumbent on us
as men to do all of these things because
the expectation from women is that we
take off 300 boxes you have to be
handsome you have to be successful you
have to be competent you have to be
Alpha you have to be beta you have to be
funny you have to be shoulder to cryon
you have to be able to solve problems
you have to be a good parent yeah like
there's a long list and men's
expectations of women are just be
beautiful and don't nag me basically
right like they like they summarize
men's needs you know for women in
comical ways like keep his nuts empty
and a stomach full right like like men
generally aren't complicated you're not
complicated animals absolutely yeah
that's why we have these comedy skits on
stuff like this right but when you ask
women or you take a look at their dating
profiles um or the expectations that
they have of men when they're dating
it's a much longer list so it's a
different set of expectations of men but
to summarize all of it like women want
to look up to a giant they want to be
with a success object right they want to
like there's absolutely no way that that
women as they get past their 20s and out
of their party years and you know
they're done with the uh hot dudes and
have expectations of provisioning and
security and all these s sorts of things
will deal with a guy that are broke they
might on a short-term basis for a
friends with benefits or a night of fun
but they don't on a long-term basis even
entertain that concept because they need
a guy that's got his stuff together so
the expectation of men is you have to
take off a lot of boxes to get women I
really hope you guys enjoyed that clip
if you want to watch the full length
podcast you can find that over here that
clips from if you're new to the channel
make sure you hit subscribe over here
and pin down below in the top comment
you'll find a bunch of useful links to
my website my supplement line books and
a bunch of other stuff have an amazing
day peace out